yeah welcome to this video bling ghefg
india vich from the US don't think that
this guy has a name in now let's briefly
check nope so we are having Kings Indian
via chat when I'm playing with the c5
now we which has posed to a symmetrical
English this line is considered
traditionally to be slightly better for
wide but nothing nothing special yeah
yeah this is so I think in fact the
recommended line in this book about the
English opening by Romanian Grandmaster
marine yeah he just played all the
smooth Bishop f5 was my idea maybe have
this looks this looks rather nice for
white Bishop f5 he can just play an
Queen a form it's not really big problem
and he's he's having see 5c 5s a very
annoying
okay let's still gain this temple good
night d 7 come on yeah don't like it
very much then I'm it feels like I'm I'm
under some pressure efore be should be
six still have this scram came I would
like to trade this and simplify I want a
97 and to make sure that c5 is not
happening interesting yeah okay wants to
take on e6 yeah this is of course a
double form but I forgot he can take
only six now because Queen D Phi takes
with the night oh this gets ugly this is
not not nice Wow ok yeah there's always
this intermediate check only six maybe
maybe it's still ok maybe I mean I'm
worse but ok in the sense of that I can
still play the position
you know I don't think it has them it
has an immediate immediate drawback you
have this this does not really scare me
much I have fun the night is not a bad
pc and the structure not at all I'm
going to see 5 and ok ok ok let's
briefly consider now I should I should
play this move let's see if I was okay
but he can play a 3 before quickly and
as I must make sure that this is not
happening how to play that now 95 still
a three but I'm a 3 i have b 5f be five
where are you going with your rook not
quite sure
what is this is not really a problem I'm
quite satisfied with the snow okay let's
check five hangs but for good king g 6
mm or the rook chicken d6 and sizes
better and then just e6 protecting f5 if
he goes look h7 I go group g76 is
protected by the night check
there's also a form a four takes would
be one check King F 294 this kind of an
activity now the nice thing is I have
the center a very nice center of course
he's got the edge porn but it's at the
moment not supported by any pieces so
Kim here and then March the pawns d5
deform would be very nice to accomplish
should I play a for have the same
probably the a porn is also just
weakness of course I forgot about the
smooth okay it's not not the end of the
world but i didn't i didn't really see
it
I didn't want to do that man
let's cut the bishop from from the
reaction 45 seconds this is this can get
get to be a problem
I know the age policy the a point is
dangerous now i misplayed that and
really badly the end game was flat-out
winning for black [ __ ] I'm pretty sure
about that ok this is at least at least
a draw I mean a draw I'm not winning or
anything but I don't think I can lose I
should be able to trade off the last
poem that he has
the some way to play for when I don't
get my learning ok ok I can take their
I'm such an idiot what back no no don't
tell me I'm still losing this crap what
the game now came black resigns yeah
this is a bit frustrating here white is
completely completely outplayed I'm just
I'm just I just just win with three
center pawns a four is slightly mistimed
of course but yeah now it's Dartz I'm
just playing complete nonsense yeah I
just can't take here and add / stopping
the edge bonus is enough I get the a
pawn okay this is the first one and here
of course I mean I shouldn't as I can
never ever lose the endgame IAM this end
game yeah this is of course course
completely drawn I can just I can just
stay put and never lose just to stay
when I forgot that you can take with the
bishop it's very stupid very stupid
mistake you can make no progress
whatsoever here if he at one point tries
to move the king I'm oops like like here
I'll break through and it's it's traded
I can just stay in and then do nothing I
completely forgot that you can take with
the bishop of course very simple ah what
a shame
dad was really enough this was just very
nice but I just played them played this
really bad lame maybe here I can also
take him this is in fact the easiest way
because he has no other right this is so
simple they only can trade this and now
it needs to even trade rooks and then I
get the H point finally just reroute
this piece and at the end the edge polar
form against this three connected ball
pawns okay thanks for watching